[Music]
he was special he could generate so much
speed and velocity that the type of
Leverage he was able to gain because he
understood the mechanics of the body he
was gliding he Glide and it was not
methodical he was spontaneous he could
fight he was versatile he was smart he
was deadly he had such a ability to
outperform anyone and he did it with
style that's what I love that he did it
with style the impact that Bruce Lee had
upon popular culture is an undeniable
fact and without a doubt he remains top
of the list in terms of the most
well-known and iconic figures in martial
arts with the ripples of his legacy
still being felt 50 years since his
death there's much debates surrounding
Bruce's actual fighting capabilities and
many are quick to dismiss his training
methods and philosoph is because it is
true that he wasn't actually tested in
combat against the top fighters of the
day like Chuck Norris and Joe Lewis but
what I don't think is Up For Debate is
that the man was a brilliant conceptual
martial artist and exceptional athlete
especially for the time that he lived
and his inspired countless individuals
to start physical training and take up
martial arts contributing to the growth
and popularity of various
[Music]
Styles so welcome to this video today
guys my name is Grant Stevens and I did
previously make a Bruce Le inspired
video that was more of a combat style
workout for martial artists that you can
find at the link in the description but
this video is going to be more like a
broad exploration of some of Bruce's
training methods philosophies and
physical Feats that contributed to his
exceptional athleticism now we'll
mention from the get-go that I'm
personally a big fan of Bruce Lee and he
was one of my original Inspirations for
taking up martial arts in the first
place but what you won't get from me in
this video is the kind of sycophantic
rhetoric that you often get from a lot
of these enamored fans that see him like
some kind of larger than life superhero
and I want to keep this video as
grounded as possible so I don't see
Bruce as the 57 140 Kung Fu G Jesus that
could beat up 62 220 Muhammad Ali which
is what many people actually believe but
if you've done even the most basic of
martial arts training you'll understand
something like that is absolutely
ridiculous my interest in Bruce isn't
related to one specific thing or another
but rather I'm inspired by his holistic
approach to personal development what he
achieved both physically and in his
career challenging the Norms of the day
and he was willing to think outside the
box and incorporate new and Innovative
approaches the man was just way ahead of
his time in so many areas as you'll come
to see in this video my personal opinion
on strictly his martial arts ability is
nuanced and I believe he was both better
than a lot of people give him credit for
but not as great as many think he was
which entirely depends upon who you're
speaking to now one thing he did possess
was incredibly fast precise and graceful
movements which we can deduce came from
his deep understanding of human
biomechanics combined with thousands
upon thousands of repetitions of
singular techniques as is documented in
his training Diaries and in terms of
pure agility and control of his physical
body Bruce was leagues above anyone I've
seen from the time period and moves far
better than a lot lot of even today's
celebrated athletes one thing that's
always impressed me about Bruce's
techniques as a martial artist myself
was just how incredibly clean and
efficient they were even by today's
standards like in this clip from way of
the Dragon in which he transitions from
a faint front snap kick into a high
roundhouse kick which is often known as
a question mark kick and this is
something that looks simple enough but
is actually quite difficult to execute
especially to this level of precision
and requires a great degree of muscular
control it's more challenging than a
regular roundhouse kick in that it
requires you to change the positioning
of the hips from a square position to a
side on position during one fluid
movement without falling off balance or
giving the game away by making the kick
labored and telegraphed I feel that pure
technical ability like this is something
that's often very underappreciated in
the eyes of modern practitioners who
tend to judge through the lens of would
it work in a fight which is really quite
a myopic perspective if the person
trains only to fight and judges whether
something is worth including based
solely on whether they can directly use
it in the ring then they deny themselves
the vast amount of benefits to be gained
by working with what are often
considered to be flamboyant movements
and how that would have a direct impact
on the fundamental skill set which would
ironically very much likely improve
their fighting ability as a result you
know what El Bruce Lee probably loved
skin care no you ever noticed how you
never see a photo of Bruce Lee looking
old Bruce Lee died young so if you want
to stay looking young Bruce Lee was
really really quick so if you want to
improve your complexion quickly then you
should try out today's sponsor T Hanley
yeah that's what I'm going with t Hanley
provides you with a simplified and
streamlined way to look after your skin
by sending a box to your door containing
all of the products you could need as
well as an instruction card showing you
exactly how and when to apply them if
you're someone who's had trouble
sticking with a skincare regime in the
past then you might just find this to be
an ideal solution for you as well I
recommend you start with their level one
system which comes with all the basics a
daily face wash to get rid of the dirt
and Grime on your skin a two times per
week exfoliating scrub to get rid of
dead skin cells an AM moisturizer with
spf20 because you should always be
protecting your skin from the sun and a
PM moisturizer to help your skin stay
hydrated and healthy throughout the
night and they now actually have over
7,000 f-star reviews from all around the
world so they must be doing something
right in addition to amazing skin
members of TSH Hanley get tons of
benefits including at least 20% off the
retail price the ability to customize
your box exclusive monthly deals the
ability to pause or cancel at any time
and free us shipping and lowcost
shipping to most other countries and
because te Hanley is sponsoring today's
video they're offering my viewers a
great deal just click the first link in
the description and you'll get 30% off
your first box plus a free gift don't
miss out on this amazing deal click the
link and get started today thanks again
to te Hanley for sponsoring this video
and now back to Grant what Bruce trained
his students in was very practical and
the philosophy was to exploit control
and dominate your opponent's Center Line
all attacks defense and and footworks
were designed to preserve your own
Center Line and open up your opponents
but with that being said he was
evidently also very proficient in the
flashier techniques due to what we saw
him do on screen and although this
served the function of being more
entertaining to audiences I'm also
inclined to believe he became so
proficient in these because he
understood the concept I Illustrated
previously and so it's clear that Bruce
had highly developed his technical
skills and was always aiming to improve
upon them but for all of the arduous
training and theoretical philosophy we
cannot make the jump to assume this
automatically made him a good fighter as
many casual fans do of course having
that skill set would put him miles ahead
of the Layman who's never trained
martial arts but against battle hardened
Fighters with high combat IQ it's a much
different story even Chu Norris who was
one of Bruce's friends and training
Partners respectfully States in this
clip that Bruce wasn't a fighter like he
was as somebody who'd entered many
tournaments of the day did you guys ever
go at it in you know in a real situation
no I was a professional fighter I you
know I fought professionally then and uh
you know he was you know Bruce was very
very good but he never fought in the
ring big difference you know kicking the
bag is one thing get in the ring and and
and uh having someone kicking back atch
is a whole different story in doing a
quick search about Bruce's real fighting
abilities it's clear that He Still
Remains a very polarizing figure with
the majority of opinions being on either
extremes of the spectrum if you hear the
stories of people that knew him
personally it's obvious that he was an
amazing martial artist and could fight
and not just some actor with no combat
ability which has become the opinion of
some popular figures in martial arts
today like chales hunen who is clearly
not a fan of Bruce if you view his
YouTube channel whenever I talk about
Bruce Lee I feel a need I have an urge
that's stronger than my ability to be
polite to make sure that I include that
he couldn't fight now that's a very
personal thing Bruce definitely engaged
in sparin and there are numerous
examples of people backing this up but
for whatever reason it always seemed to
be against his students over which he'd
obviously have a massive advantage and
other than the 1967 Long Beach
International footage there isn't really
any other clips of him actually sparring
and this is despite him definitely
having access to camera equipment The
Long Beach footage is certainly not bad
but I think it's safe to say that it
doesn't match up to the legendary
greatest fighter ever status bestowed
upon Him by many fans and once again the
opponents he's facing who were his
students also don't look overly
competent but to play Devil's Advocate
this footage was from 1967 and Bruce
died in 73 and we do know that he was
continually building upon and developing
his skills so perhaps this isn't the
most accurate representation but really
it's all we've got to go off rather than
just relying upon hear saying stories
there are still many casual fans who are
under the impression that because he
could move well and trained hard that
automatically meant he was a great
fighter and in many cases even going as
far as to say things like he would
obliterate decorated Legends who
exceeded his weight class like Mike
Tyson from these statements it's quite
easy to recognize these people aren't
martial artists themselves because what
they misunderstand is that while being
able to move physically well is
undeniably a crucial element that makes
a person a good fighter it's only one
part of the puzzle there are many other
traits arguably more important than this
such as fight IQ which can't be
developed in any other way than vast
amounts of ring experience we also need
to consider a Fighter's ability to
manage the adrenaline that comes from
combat which can cause even people with
vast training experience to forget all
of their skills until they learn to
manage it through repeated exposure
however on the other side of the
spectrum we've got people that say he
was just a movie star and completely
disregard his ability and understanding
of the martial arts so what is the truth
then well I would say the answer lies
somewhere in the middle of those two
viewpoints Bruce certainly wasn't the
greatest fighter ever yet he was
definitely not just an actor who did
fight scenes the opinions that he was
the latter tend to come from people who
have trained in combat Arts which is
understandable because these people have
some skin in the game but in my
experience as a martial artist you have
to be quite a freethinker and
open-minded to appreciate what Bruce Lee
did and achieved and if you think all
the RIS of martial arts is fighting then
you're going to miss the forest through
the trees but conversely if you think
all the is to fighting is being good at
techniques then you're also way off a
common argument is that people say Bruce
only trained for the street and didn't
like the point karate competitions that
were around in his day and that may be
true but to me this is hedging towards
that cringy territory where martial art
is say things like these techniques are
so deadly that we can't even demonstrate
them and it's not widely known that they
were in fact valy to competitions taking
place in Bruce's day that were close to
a no holds bad format so it's not as if
the only option was the point stop
karate but for reasons we'll never know
Bruce wasn't inspired to participate in
them when researching information about
Bruce it can be tricky because of the
limited technology of the time period
coupled with the cult of Bruce Lee
phenomenon which is exacerbated by
inamed fans who grew up on his movies
and view him kind of like a superhero
and they perpetuate many of the
Preposterous claims like he could kick
six times in one second or that he could
throw a grain of rice in the air and
catch it between two chopsticks but
ultimately I would say this stuff
actually harms Bruce's reputation and
for some people can act a little bit
like a turd in the punch bowl putting
them off Bruce entirely which is a real
shame because there's a lot to learn
from the man I also feel that Bruce
actually wouldn't be very happy with all
of this stuff and he made it clear that
the things he did on screen were for
entertainment purposes as seen in this
statement from a letter to his friend
although Bruce was a very confident and
some would say cocky individual he
didn't view himself as some kind of
fighting Guru or God he enjoyed working
with other martial artists of the day to
learn from each other and even said him
self that he'd kill me in a fight when
referring to the question if he could
defeat Muhammad Ali if you're enjoying
this video so far I'd like to invite you
to come over to my channel And subscribe
at youtube.com/ grrand Steensma it's
focused upon all things Martial Arts
Fitness and mental discipline so Bruce's
martial arts training began in Wing Chum
when he was a teenager but through
experience and exposure to other martial
artists in America he came to the
conclusion that Wing Chum was just too
limited which inspired him to create his
own philosophy known
as The Way of the intercepting fist kidy
wasn't really a style like how other
martial arts may be defined and he
referred to it as using no way as way
meaning that there's no single way style
system or Focus that is the best
all-encompassing martial art and by
opening your mind to embrace study
analyze and evaluate all fighting
possibilities then you don't limit your
potential this cross trainining approach
is now quite common place due to the
rise of MMA into the mainstream and
because of that we now have this kind of
martial arts training setup that is
designed to produce a competent fighter
but we need to remember that when Bruce
lived in the' 60s and' 7s this was not
mainstream by any means and was actually
considered by some as a sacrilege to the
sacred Doctrine many of these
traditional styles unquestioningly
adhered to a gospel truth and a lot of
what they believed and subsequently
focused on was in line with the way
things had always been done Bruce viewed
this as a stagnant approach and instead
he believed that the individual training
in the martial art was far more
important than any style or system which
can be seen in his Black Belt Magazine
article liberate yourself from classical
karate in which he stated a style should
never be considered gospel truth the
laws and principles of which can never
be violated man the living creating
individual is always more important than
any established style now I want to just
highlight a common misconception that I
think some people will inevitably pick
up on which was that Bruce was certainly
not the first ever person to begin
experimenting in Cross training as I
mentioned earlier there were already old
school valet tudo tournaments in Bruce's
day and even in the ancient Greek
Olympics there was an empty-hand
submission sport in which the athletes
mixed striking and grappling techniques
with scarcely any rules Bruce is still
considered to be vastly ahead of his
time in this regard which is certainly
was but really it's only when compared
to traditional martial artists of the
day and I think it's important to
mention that just to give the other
pioneers of the time credit Bruce's
iconic status often eclipses this
especially to Casual onlookers which
leads them to believe that he was in
fact the first one when in fact he was
more like the person that became most
well known for it and so in changing the
focus from the power being in the style
with its rules and limitations and
instead placing it upon the individual
essentially JKD became a limitless
non-bias approach that became about
practicality efficiency and the idea of
adopting only what was useful from
various martial arts Styles while
disregarding what wasn't it also
emphasized directness Simplicity and
non-classical movements and instead was
interested in finding out what was
actually the most effective and so not
only did this open the door to using any
and all martial arts techniques that
would be effective in combat it also
naturally made sense to Bruce to do the
same with his conditioning and we see
this overarching pattern in which he
recognized the limitations of
traditional methods and also applied a
similar open-minded and inclusive
approach to everything that he did again
this is something that's common place
now martial arts training and physical
conditioning are synonymous with one
another but in Bruce's day this wasn't
the case at all which is reflected in a
quote I've always really liked in which
he said training is one of the most
neglected phases of Athletics too much
time is given to the development of
skill and too little to the development
of the individual for participation I
remember reading in Matthew pol's
brilliant book Bruce Le a life that
apparently in those days some martial
artists used to Pride themselves on
drinking loads of alcohol and then have
fights and considered this to be
masculine said the connection between
care of the physical vessel and
performance hadn't yet been made and
this is also something mirrored in many
other sports like football in the UK at
the time traditional Styles's idea of
conditioning was maybe doing a few
push-ups at the beginning of class and
we can see this nowadays with the
improvements in the physiques of combat
athletes compared to back in the day
they actually look a lot more like Bruce
did then which is as a result of his
belief in conditioning and physical
development when we see Bruce on the big
screen it's easy to think that he was
just destined to become what we know him
as today but what many people don't know
about Bruce is that he was anything but
a naturally gifted athlete in in fact he
actually had one leg shorter than the
other he was quite a sickly child and he
had to do a lot of work to build up his
body into the physique that is so
recognizable with that being said though
naysayers will point to Bruce's
relatively small measurements and less
impressive lifts as proof that he wasn't
particularly strong his arms only
measured 13 in at the time of Enter the
Dragon for example this is very small by
any bodybuilder standards and his gym
records show that he squatted £95 for 10
reps during a regular workout but on the
other side of the spectrum you hear
ludicrous claims that he could raise a
45 barbell to shoulder height with his
arm straight and hold it there for
minutes at a time or hold a vit for half
an hour so what's the actual truth well
it's highly unlikely that he was
actually able to hold out the dumbbell
arms length as described and that would
be a amazing feat of strength for anyone
not saying it's impossible but the fact
he never film this ability like with the
sparin is a little suspect given that he
wasn't shy of demonstrating his strength
but what we do have record of is that he
was able to perform Almost Perfect Two
finger push-ups watching his technique
we can see that his feet are close
together and his core remains almost
perfect perfectly rigid the entire time
most people performing a one-handed
push-up will let their waist sag and
spay their feet apart to manage it let
alone doing it using two fingers so what
it comes down to is really how we
measure strength you know as Adam is
continually stating on this channel
overall strength can't be determined
just by how well you perform on the big
lifts which is only one expression of
strength Bruce clearly had an incredibly
strong Corum finger strength which
lightly translated to excellent grip
strength you can see his core strength
simply by observing the way he moves his
energy is very well contained and no
matter how aggressive he initiates a
strike which is a Hallmark of good form
in martial arts and those with weakness
in this area can be prone to fall off
balance and strike with lackluster force
and as for those 95b squats this
actually makes perfect sense given
Bruce's goals he was first and foremost
a martial artist and opted to add weight
training to give himself more explosive
power and strength not only does he not
need to develop a huge squat to serve
this purpose but training with extremely
heavy weights would only serve to take
away from his martial arts training
fatigue management is big in the world
of functional training and his Jim
sessions needed to complement his
primary Sport and he was not doing ego
lifts to put on more size it also
wouldn't make sense for Bruce to get
very large and heavy and apparently
there was a time when he did bulk up a
little bit to about 165 lb but
recognized it really slowed him down and
so returned to his regular 140 by using
techniques like speed lifting and
overcoming isometrics which fits
perfectly with how many modern Fighters
approaching a match will aim to cut
their weight down while maintaining as
much of their power as possible in short
Bruce wasn't powerlifter strong but what
we can gather is that he had an iron
core a very powerful grip and an amazing
ability to generate power in other words
he had functional strength in Spades
from his training records we can see
that his dedication was exceptional and
he trained like a professional athlete
and something I don't see mention
regularly but I think deserves a mention
is that the majority of his training and
physical development was done purely
through his own dedication and obsession
with his craft and He was largely
self-trained outside of the early years
which is very different to Modern
athletes who have a team of coaches to
cater for specific areas of their own
development and essentially have a plan
laid out for them of course this doesn't
take anything away from their work ethic
but we have to ponder whether they would
have such dedication if they were having
to do all of the research and testing
themselves without the support of that
team so I hope you enjoyed this video I
attempted to include as much as possible
regarding what we know about Bruce and
provide a neutral and realistic
presentation of his abilities and
achievements as I mentioned already when
researching Bruce Lee it can be tricky
to separate signal from noise and that's
the reason I said in the beginning that
he was both better than many give him
credit for but not as great as many
think he was which I hope has been made
clear throughout this video I've taken
into consideration the' 60s and ' 70s
was a very different era and as with
most things in life the standard of
skill and understanding has improved
considerably and semi-serious martial
artists today will likely be better than
the elites of the past purely because of
phenomena like the hundreds monkey
effect and advances in knowledge over
time we have to remember that Bruce died
in 1973 which was 50 years ago so to
answer the common question how would
Bruce fear in today's MMA I think if you
plucked him from the period and placed
him in the cage in 2023 he'd have a hell
of a struggle and would likely be
defeated by the majority of today's Pros
which I think is a very fair assessment
this will inevitably trigger many of the
cultists but as I've already touched on
these opinions tend to come from an
uneducated perspective in which these
people don't understand the specialized
skills and experience that you'd only be
able to get through extensive training
with the goal of competing against the
best in the world but if we
hypothetically imagine Bruce Lee as a
modern martial artist with access to
contemporary knowledge and who was
training for that goal then I think it's
a much different story in terms of just
his athleticism and ability he probably
had the best Foundation one could ask
for and with the right training I think
he'd have the potential to become a
world champion at the highest level some
of the things he would have to do would
be develop a more well-rounded skill set
especially focusing more upon grappling
because although he did train this he
was clearly striking focused again many
accounts of Bruce's sparing matches
contain anecdotes about his speed and
how tough he was to hit but what happens
when an experienced Grappler manages to
take him down he'd also take advantage
of advancements in understanding and if
he was training to compete in MMA
professionally he'd likely enlist the
skills of coaches specialized in
particular areas of knowledge like a
nutritionist or a conditioning expert
regardless of the opinion you hold on
the man his exceptional athleticism was
a result of his dedication Innovation
and holistic approach to training that
integrated physical fitness martial arts
mental discipline and adaptability his
influence extends beyond the realm of
martial arts making him an enjoing icon
in the World of Sports and popular
culture thank you very much for
watching